generally speaking you know because you
got your your [__] your farm fash
Facebook Uncle
Fred sitting at the table talking about
all kinds of crazy [__] he read on the
the interwebs well it says on there that
Joe Biden he doesn't have wrinkly balls
it says he doesn't have balls at all
that's what I read on those
interwebs back to the wrinkly balls
right but your your your farm fash
Facebook Uncle Fred uh is definitely
going to say [__] at the the table on
Thanksgiving and you know you're going
to punch back with the with the um the
government shutdown stuff and you might
just
convince your farm fash Facebook Uncle
Fred
that what you're saying about the
shutdown and the Republicans being not
able to govern is true and that's the
problem that they don't want right they
don't don't want to have that that in
the American discourse at that point nor
do they want the narrative that the the
Republicans are responsible
for the Republicans are responsible
Everyone likes the Uncle Fred thing uh
yeah well Farm Fresh fash Uncle Fred
Facebook Uncle Fred but it looks like
rant's got a picture of us for the farm
fresh Facebook Vash here is the oh my
god wow this is really accurate here is
the farm fresh Facebook fash here H this
is your Uncle Fred you'll be talking to
him and he's he's canning those green
beans you know last week we had him
canning green beans here's that's that
that's wild that's how fast it was look
how great that is folks can you believe
that stuff look at
that you talking about AI working fast
quick and in a
hurry that's crazy but there is um
there's there's the farm fresh fash
Uncle Fred Facebook Uncle
Fred um this is what AI can
do oh my god oh someone says fesus no
it's Uncle Fred fesus is their is their
grandpappy he was the farm fresh fast
Festus and really honestly you know
that's the weird part you know then that
we're talking about this is that a lot
of these fies thanks rat I appreciate
all the the help for the technical
difficulties and and thanks for the um
the AI Biden video keeping that going um
this is the weird part about this in
like American discourse and rural areas
that at one point in this country you
know you you you kind of see these
people like oh our farm has been in our
generation for for or been in our family
for three generations my grandp pey's
grandpy what they don't know is during
like the Great
Depression the original socialist in
this country were the
farmers the farm bill is
socialism it's socialism by Design like
they don't understand that it's weird
stuff speaking of Facebook and Farm
Fresh fash it's like years ago when
Obama was still the
president um when Obama was the
president and they were working on the
farm bill and Republicans for years
really tried to separate the farm bill
and or get Weare out of the farm bill so
the farm subsidies and and food stamps
were always in the farm bill the reason
why is that's what makes it
work that's why it worked for for so
long that's why it worked still is that
what you do is you provide government
money the government buys the food food
right if the farmer can't sell it on the
open market they buy the food byy
subsidy that's what you're doing is
you're buying
it and then the people who can't afford
to
buy in Market food at like a grocery
store where the farmer you know makes
their food and then distributes it to
the grocery store through different
Supply chains and then the end user goes
to the grocery store to buy it if they
can't afford to buy it the government's
like we'll give you food stamp
that way we don't have poor ass Farmers
not being able to afford to live on
farms and people who will pay them to
make the food and then we'll make sure
the people who need the food can eat it
makes sense right and it works it
[__] works not only does it work it
works exceptionally well because it's
called what is that word called economy
that's what it's called it's a great
economy it creates an economy and a
market o o baby these capitalists really
love those type of words
right but they don't understand that
farm subsidies is socialism so years ago
when Obama was trying to work on getting
the farm bill passed and it it didn't
seem like he was going to get a pass I
literally had friends in my rule town
that were posting on Facebook you know
along with the the farm fresh fash
Facebook Uncle Fred they were posting on
Facebook oh they need to pass this this
Farm bills so us farmers can get our
subsidies we need our
subsidies and then the same
feed as the farm fresh Facebook Uncle
Fred they were like but we don't want
people to have food
stamps that damn you lazy people having
food stamps like holy [__] how don't you
get that you're making
food and that the government making sure
that people who who can't eat or can't
afford to eat are eating with I don't
know money gets back in your pocket how
do you not understand
this this is easy stuff like abc1 two3
type
[__] and they were bitching about the
farm bill not being passed and they were
bitching about food stamps being
passed wild [__] because it's the old
the old thing that I say several times
I've said it several times on the show I
want my rich white welfare but I don't
want you to have your poor Brown welfare
because that's truly how they feel about
it that's truly how they feel about it
there's there's there's rich white
that's that's earned that's earned
benefits but you poor brown people
you're a Scourge on our country even
though there's no proof in that and and
matter of fact there's proof to the
opposite that people who come here
migrants and other other
populations actually work their asses
off and they get paid less they get less
money for the same work the same output
dumb Dum and the one reason why is
because you're getting our tax dollars
to grow the food to make sure people who
are hungry have it to eat and really
we've done a piss Bo job since Nixon if
you really want to go back into the
history of it of feeding people now some
states are coming on board and some
people have come to the realization that
we actually have the infrastructure to
feed families in this country we we have
the infrastructure it's a very easy
infrastructure we use the infrastructure
every [__] day in this country to
feed families every day we use this
infrastructure it's called School
cafeterias we literally have built an
entire infrastructure in this country
that not only educates people but feeds
them every day every single school has
some sort of cafeteria inside of it
Elementary uh middle school high school
wherever it may be those public schools
have
cafeterias and uh cafeterias are
designed to uh what is it feed people so
we have the infrastructure that feeds
families every single day in this
country and during the pandemic if you
remember a lot of people couldn't afford
school lunches because I don't know
there was a
pandemic so what the government did is
said you know what we're going to do
we're going to make all lunch free lunch
we're not going to charge anybody we're
going to pay for the lunch for every
single student in this country to eat
and by doing that the government paid
for families to eat it's actually a
really simple infrastructure it it
exists already come on yeah it was just
it was just like talking abouts Stu well
I I actually I think the U Farm Fresh
fash let me show you um so we've got a
farm fresh fash yeah we've got a new uh
new thing we're going with here it's
called The Farm the farm fresh fash but
it's your farm to table fascism well
well Facebook to
table